what's going on guys this is Rob and in
this video we're going to be explaining
the character of Modoc which is
something that we should have done quite
some time ago however towards the end
we're going to take a break away from
our traditional character explanation
format and I actually want to do a
little bit of speculation on what we
could potentially be seeing in Ant-Man
and wasp quantumania because it's really
cool to see Modoc actually being done
right so Modoc was created by Stan Lee
and Jack Kirby and first appeared in
Tales of suspense issues 93 and 94 back
in 1967 and at the time Stan Lee was
really looking to create a new and
unique character that could basically
stand out from the crowded comic book
Market as it existed at the time which
is one thing that people tend to forget
between about 1962 and 1970 that eight
year period Marvel had a massive influx
of characters that were either being
created for the first time or being
brought back which was the case of like
Captain America created by Jack Kirby
and Joe Simon back in the 1940s but the
reality here is that Stan Lee wanted to
create a villain that was different from
the traditional physical monsters that
have been popular up to that point and
Modoc was really the result of that
effort Stanley also wanted to create a
villain that was terrifying and not just
because of his physical appearance but
because of his intellect and his ability
to out think and outmaneuver his enemies
and so Modoc was created as a physical
representation of this idea with his
large bulbous head basically
representing his incredible intellect
now of course modoc's creation also
reflects the Cold War era of paranoia
that existed at that point in time and
the reason why I say that and this is
something important to understand is
that Marvel Comics back before 1968 in a
lot of ways reflected the real world now
the reason why I say 1968 is that
there's actually a fan theory that goes
on out there that Franklin Richards
controls the Marvel Universe and I know
it sounds strange to talk about that in
the middle of a Modoc video but bear
with me here the idea is that Franklin
Richards was introduced in Marvel Comics
in 1968 that was the same year that
Marvel Comics actually had a kind of
initiative to stop referencing real
world events and instead to basically
focus on having Comics being this
situation where everything was is
basically Timeless there was no
particular reference to a real world
time frame that shifted over the years
and really in more recent years you see
like dates being thrown out and years
being thrown out that kind of gives us
an indication of where Marvel Comics
resides in relation to us as the real
world but to our point about the Cold
War era itself running from the 1960s up
to the mid-1980s the paranoia of the
Cold War is that you didn't know if
something that you said would be
reported to the authorities and they
would come knocking on your door asking
if you're a communist or if it was
someone that you were talking to who was
actually a communist spy now the latter
of that which is to say people being
communist spies while that did exist it
was actually an unfounded fear being
drummed up by politicians the news and
even just Everyday People it took on a
life of its own in a lot of ways and so
modoc's creation reflected that fear in
paranoia and this idea that the enemy
could simply be hiding in plain sight
using their intellect and Technology to
outsmart and outmaneuver everybody now
Modoc of course is often considered to
be a reflection of Stan Lee's own
personal insecurities and even his own
personal demons that Modoc being written
as a tragic figure and his drive and
desire to prove himself and to be
accepted despite his physical
limitations is all a reflection of this
because if you look at modoc's character
Beyond just whatever scheme he's
implementing in the Marvel universe
that's really the core of his motivation
to be genuinely accepted by the people
around him but in turn lashing out
because he's not now Modoc has had
different Origins over the years in
Marvel Comics and these Origins do come
from different places Captain America
Issue Number 20 the original Tales of
suspense issues number 93 and 94 stories
There Was An Origin that was written in
the 1990s by the long and short of his
origin is that he was a guy named George
Tarleton that was associated with
Advanced idea mechanics now the reason
why I say Associated is because
depending on what origin you're reading
some stories say that he was a janitor
other stories say that he was a
scientist but the important thing here
is that at that point in time Advanced
idea mechanics where it initially
started off as the science wing of Hydra
had branched out to become its own thing
and what it was looking to do was to
basically conquer the world and then
lead the World using Science and
Technology with aim being in charge of
everything and so in an effort to do
this what they wanted to do was create a
Cosmic Cube now for those of you guys
who are unfamiliar with Cosmic cubes and
it kind of sidetracked from Modoc for a
second Cosmic cubes are artifacts of
astronomical power and while we didn't
initially know how they originated in
Marvel Comics over the years we've
gotten more nuanced explanations that
all basically came together to
essentially tell us that Cosmic cubes
are basically containment vessels for
the energy of the Beyond verse where the
beyonders reside the important thing
about that is the Beyond verse houses
just insurmountable levels of energy
right it's literally infinite power if
you can contain it now to answer the
question that people are undoubtedly
going to ask what if someone tries to
create a Cosmic Cube and they don't have
a containment device to put it into you
and it goes into themselves you end up
with a molecule man Owen Reese but for
George Talton himself and really just
for advanced idea mechanics because they
wanted to be able to create a Cosmic
Cube and then study the Cosmic Cube to
understand its power the effects of a
cube could be far-reaching they didn't
quite know what would happen so what
they did is they transformed George
Tarleton into Modoc which initially
stood for mental organism designed only
for computing the problem with this is
that as his Cranium increased in size
and he became more intelligent his
ambition increased as well and what it
led to was Modoc basically turning on
Advanced idea mechanics seizing control
of the organization and then renaming
himself mental organism designed only
for killing and just kind of went
forward from there now after his debut
in Tales of suspense issue number 93
Modoc quickly became a recurring villain
in multiple Marvel comic book stories
like Captain America he also appeared in
Iron Man issue 74-75 as well as the cree
scroll War story line and Avengers
issues 89-97 although admittedly
everybody was in that story now one of
the important things about Modoc and
this is something to grasp while his
character was shown as exceedingly
dangerous and very very significant in
the older stories as time progressed
that began to change now this is
something we've talked about before more
in Marvel Comics when you had villains
that Rose to prominence in the 1960s and
70s that either Marvel didn't really
know what to do with them so you ended
up seeing them just kind of bouncing
around the landscape and then ultimately
disappearing entirely or Marvel would
experience a paradigm shift in terms of
how their characters were being handled
in the case of Modoc it was more of a
Marvel Paradigm Shift when you looked at
stories like the Incredible Hulk issue
number 168 in 1973 by Steve ingleheart
and Herb trimp this is one of those
times when Modoc was given to us as an
exceedingly serious character because in
a desire to find a way to defeat the
Incredible Hulk he ended up humping
Betty Ross full of gamma radiation and
that turned her into Harpy and so going
forward from there really into the 1980s
the character maintained a level of
significance but under the leadership of
Jim shooter who had taken over following
Roy Thomas that Marvel wanted to focus
more on stories that could draw readers
in and sell merchandise in the case of
their deal with Mattel as far as Secret
Wars went but at the same time Jim
shooter was looking to the stories
involving John Byrne and the Fantastic
Four as well as Chris Claremont in the
X-Men in order to draw in readers by
focusing on characters with a more
personalized element of Storytelling the
reality here is Modoc didn't really fit
that bill Modoc was a character that was
born in bread in an era of Marvel Comics
when it was a kind of villain who was
dangerous facing off against superheroes
and that was effectively it and so going
into the 1990s with Captain America
issues 311 to 314 there was an attempt
to rework modok to make him a more
sympathetic villain which ran in stark
contrast to Marvel Comics at the time
which was to focus on heroes and
villains that were more High Octane and
fast-paced than what we got in this
story really more by way of exposition
as opposed to any kind of tangible
flashback was that in truth George
Tarleton didn't want to be turned into
Modoc that it was actually done against
his will that it was more of a tragic
situation as opposed to a guy who would
succumb to some sort of scientific
experiment gone mad with Incredible
levels of power and intelligence and
then took over aim and just been running
it as a criminal ever since there was
the death of modak at the hands of the
serpent Society but the truth about this
is that because Marvel was struggling in
the 1990s as we've talked about so many
times before with the comic bust though
there wasn't really any room for Marvel
to focus on a character like Modoc who
just didn't really have a lot of drive
and interest from readers now because of
that what you saw was him just sort of
being shuffled to the background he was
eventually brought back by Advanced idea
mechanics in an attempt to pick up where
his predecessor had left off ultimately
it wasn't necessarily successful but
going into the 2000s under the
leadership of Joe Casada Marvel Comics
specifically when it came to Modoc
actually became more comedic it became
more of a nonsensical character it took
away from the significance of what made
him what he was he'd always been treated
as a villain that was significant he was
a villain that when he showed up that it
wouldn't necessarily instill fear in
characters across the entirety of the
Marvel Universe sure Dr Doom had some
measure of fear of him but in truth he
was a character that was just kind of
comedic most of the time in the
background the rest of the time and so
you did get these Sparks in these
moments where he would be involved in
these campaigns there would just blow
the mind of the people who were reading
his stories because it was something
that you didn't really see and in a lot
of ways was a throwback to the old Modoc
a perfect example of this was the
intelligencia so the intelligencia was a
coming together of the different
villains across Marvel Comics but
specifically the most intelligent
villains and one of the things the
intelligence he had done is they had
actually turned on Dr Doom and stripped
him of pretty much all of his genius
aptitude but with that moment it
established that Modoc was still a
credible threat in Marvel Comics The
issue is that in more recent years in
Marvel when you're focusing on stories
like Jordan Bloom's Modoc head games
which is a great story in his own right
or his appearances in gwenpool he's more
of a toned down comedic character he
seems more nonsensical than serious and
honestly he's really been that way ever
since now as far as the MCU goes if I'm
being honest with you guys I think it's
going to be a return to form for the
true Modoc that we know I hope it's not
going to go in the direction of more of
like the comedic character that I think
we're gonna see a more dangerous version
of his character I think that is also
going to tie into the events of the
original Ant-Man series we know just
from the casting and the look of the
character and so on that he's basically
or at least looks like an alternate
reality version of Darren cross the main
villain from Ant-Man 2. I would go as
far as to surmise that he's the result
of some kind of scientific experiment
gone wrong whether or not it has
anything to do with a Cosmic Cube like
the original origin from the comics when
it came to Modoc I'm not entirely sure
truth to tell if I'm a betting man I
would say it probably has something to
do with Pim particles that some
misunderstanding or incorrect usage led
to him taking on his current form
whether or not he'll have any of the
psychic powers that we're familiar with
Modoc having which is to say telepathy
telekinesis mind control along with his
doomsday chair being able to amplify
those abilities that's anybody's guess
we don't really know until the movie
comes out but I would go as far as to
say that with this seemingly being an
alternate reality version of Darren
cross that my prediction for the events
of King Dynasty and Secret Wars are
ringing true that what we're seeing is
that this is going to basically
culminate in Avengers forever by a
different name that is going to have
different members of The Avengers but
from different realities an alternate
reality version of Captain America an
alternate reality version of Iron Man
most likely the main Marvel Cinematic
Universe version of Scott Lang played by
Paul Rudd now they're all going to
effectively unify and that what you're
going to have as far as Kane the
Conqueror is concerned is his alternate
reality counterpart to that right you
can call it the dark Avengers if you
want to but his version of different
superheroes from across the Multiverse
that are all basically villains in their
own right I wouldn't be surprised if
Wanda is one of those but again we're
digressing here and getting off point as
far as Modoc is concerned he's one of
those tried and true examples of
characters in Marvel Comics that was
initially introduced as being
exceedingly dangerous and quite powerful
in his own way but over the years in
Marvel has just kind of been shuffled
back to the background and then when he
was brought back was made more comedic
because in truth Marvel never really saw
any serious elements to his character
and didn't quite know how to write him
in a way that made him serious or kept
him serious so with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end
thank you all for watching and I will
catch you all later peace